οι διαδικασίες εκάσαμε κατό ευκαλάμε και δεκα εξιδεκαυτά προτάσεις ιδικά για το τι να γίνει
όχιόχι τι δεν έγινε και κάμαεμε μόρατόριου το λέο συχνά μόρατόριουν στον αλέμε τι δεν
έγινε το ίδιον εκάναμε στην προσέλκη σην επιχείρησεαστην προσερχειση επιχειρήσεω θέσαμε έν ένα θέμα αρχικά
το γενάρι και είπαμε προέδρια κυβέρνηση φαίνεται ότι προσέλκεισε επιχειρήσε ων έχει μιωθεί στην κύπρο
ακολούθησε μια διαδικασία που ακολούθησε ν ο πρόεδρος αν δεν καπλολάθσου με τα πριντρν με
τοπροσέρχεισ επιεριώσουν στην αμερική κια τα λιπά κιτα λοιπά εσχολιάσαμε τον τρόπο που έγινε στο
σχολιάσαμε η ουσία όμως ένίταν τότι ουσία ήταν όταν εγινα κάποιος αλλαγές οι οποιεσε να
βελτιώσουν των τρόπο με τον οποίο πάρετο μα στο ψώπια της επιχειρίσεις ύρταμε τύπαε και
πρόεδρε ένα δύοτρίατέρα πέντε έξη υπάρχουν και τούτα τα πράγματά τα οποία ακίνουν θα γίνει
πολύ καλύτερος ο τρόπος με τον οποίών υποδεχόμαστε ταισε επιχειρίσεις πο τον εξωρικόν αλλά και
εξυπηρετούμεται σε επιχειρίσει στην κύπρο διότι όντως για μας επιχειρηματικό δα ενένα που τα βασικά
μας πυ τις βασικές μας χαρακτηριστικάαν παράταξη και θεωρούενα ότι μέσον αυτής τσι που επιτι
χάνεται η α η ανάπτυξη αρά εμάς ήταν βασική μας γνια την ίδιανόρα και την
ίδια περίοδο κάποιαμε διαβούλευση με τον υπιχειριματικώ τομέα μ εξεφτάσευ ναντίσει μεταμε τις κύριους δομές
του επιχρηματικό τομέα άρα ι έκανε σε τούμε την περίπταση το συμβούλια έτσι όπο στα
περιάγραψα ξεκίνησε να αναδεικνίοντας ένα θέμα να αντιπολιευτικά έκασε συγκεντρώθηκε να παράξει προτάσεις και για
για ποιολο για να κάμει τη δουλειά της ηκυβέρνηση όι για να κάμουμε τη δουλειά
μας ούλη και ολοι όλοι και